Chuyên thông nha nước Irang hôm nay sẽ nhận lãnh tụi tối cao Ali khảm này tảm vi sảo tuổi đã qua đời trong cuộc khống kích của nhi và Iswin tại bán phòng làm việc khi đáng thực hiện các nhiệm buộc trong một tình bố,
lưỡng lượng vệ bình kế mạng của giá Irang đã bị tạo tích thương trước sự ra đi của lãnh rất là một người. Chuyên thông viên Rang của tự tin,
bố nước Irang của lãnh tụi cao Ali khảm nha của một số tương lĩnh và còn chức cấp cao nước này đã thích mạng trong cuộc khống kích của Nhi và Iswin.
Theo tổ chức trọng lưỡng lượng đò của Irang đã có hơn hai trong người thịt mạng và gần bệ trăm năm mươi đã bị thương trong chiến dịch không biết của Mỹ và Iswin vào Irang trong những qua.
Giêng của không biết của Iswin và Chuyên tụi học lưỡng tại Minna đã cấp đi sinh mạng của hơn một chắc người trong đò phần lưỡng nạn nhân điều là học sinh.
Mọi trưởng Irang, A Phas, Arak Chuy, ngày lực tức lên án mạng mạng, hành động tấn công nhằm vào những đưa trẻ vụ tổ và một tả đây là tối át chống lại người dần Irang.
Hà Min tự cho một số 3 mốt tình của Irang bị ai hưởng một chiến dịch tấn công của Iswin và Mỹ.
Tổng tổng Irang mà xuất tư dây kia linh án các vụ tấn công là anh động vô nhân đạo.
Đông tối với câu cơ cơ quan tí trợ hình trường hỗ trợ nạn nhân.
Trong sáng nay, Iswin và Irang vẫn tiếp tục mở các quộ thuốc tích và lãnh trộ của nhau.
Huyện sáng nay, Irang tiếp tục tục đón đắt chả nhằm vào các cẩn cứ quên sử của Mỹ Iswin và nhiều một kêu khác các trình đông.
Như cố quét, cà ta cất tựu của phố đặt của nhất và par anh làm giống truyền các khu vực đông dân cư.
Gây gián đoạn hoạt động hàng không và vực trình dù mào.
Hàng loạt thiên ở Irang đã sáng nào bầu trường bị rơi dân nhiều vụ nổ lưỡng và khi những người dân tự phương hỏng sợ tìm nơi truan.
Cơ quan đường có khẩn có có giải Iswin ghi nhận một người thiệt mạng và một chăm tham em một người bí thương,
và lúc bị đường hẹn sợ các cuộc tập kích của Irang, nhằm vào lãi đồn này trong nền qua.